le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
avec près de quatorze mille naissances
chaque année à la réunion donner un
accès égal à la prévention et au suivi
médical des enfants est un enjeu de
taille
géré par le département les pm les
services de protection maternelle et
infantile propose un accompagnement
gratuit destiné à tous de la
consultation ont suivi de l'enfant
rencontre avec des professionnels de ces
centres qui nous parlent de leur métier
[Musique]
hahaha
juni on n'est pas pour moi un jour
savoir m
[Musique]
alors julie on se voit aujourd'hui
c'était pourtant non renouvellement de
pilules ça se passe bien pour toi des
questions une consultation une
prescription
les centres de pmi sont à la disposition
de l'enfance et de la famille grâce à
une équipe pluridisciplinaire de
professionnels de santé les centres
proposent un suivi médical un
accompagnement psychosocial et des
conseils pour les modes de garde des
enfants au cpif de saint denis
nathalie devaux médecin reçoit ce jour
là des jeunes filles aiment beaucoup de
jeunes filles qui aiment bien venir ici
parce que elles disent que c'est souvent
tabou dans leurs familles pensent que
leurs parents sont peut-être courant
mais vraiment la difficulté par les est
difficile et donc par contre ici elles
deviennent vraiment toute confiance
poser des questions qui font et elles
savent qu'on leur homme à passer du
temps avec elle quand tu prends tes
pilules toi jean monnet monde en tout on
sent le stérilet leurs moines qui est
d'internet elle va que dans son utérus
elle va pas enrayer corps donc ça permet
c'est encore mieux
c'est gratuit pour les mineurs tout est
pris en charge pour les mineurs et la
consultation qui est anonyme book et la
faune et la contraception
c'est un service de droit commun
c'est-à-dire que toute personne peut
venir dans notre service
mais dans ce cas on va prendre la carte
vitale mais en pas du tout
les mutuelles et puis aussi on se rend
vraiment un service qui permet pour les
personnes les plus vulnérables en
situation de précarité faut c'est
évidemment la consulter sur mail
gratuite et on va fournir aussi les
contraceptions les centres pmi s'adresse
à toutes les femmes à différentes étapes
de leur vie pendant une grossesse et
rencontreront différents professionnels
toujours dans la même structure à la pmi
de bois de nèfles saint paul les mamans
et les enfants sont accueillis pour
partager un moment ensemble
j'assure un accueil j'assure
l'explication du service
l'objectif du lieu d'accueil je met à
l'aise les mamans et je propose des
petites activités autour du genou et
enfants autour de la manipulation et de
préparation à l'école
du coup on fait tous le lap lieu
d'accueil parents-enfants permet aux
enfants de se sociabiliser avant
l'entrée en maternelle et aux parents de
rencontrer d'autres personnes pour
échanger sur leur vie de famille elles
peuvent rencontrer pendant la grossesse
donc c'est plus la sage femme
après en général on présente
l'auxiliaire la puéricultrice et ensuite
au moment de la naissance du bébé
rencontre la puéricultrice l'auxiliaire
si elles viennent en consultation elle
rencontre le médecin et s'il ya besoin
par la suite si elles veulent venir en
pmi ou c'est un besoin à la maison elles
pourront rencontrer éducatrice nous
faisons un accompagnement personnalisé
en fonction des besoins sur l'île 23
centres pmi neuf centres de
planification et d'éducation familiale
réponse aux différentes demandes des
parents ou futurs parents sans doute
permis ce sont des centres à vocation
universelle tout le monde a droit à
accès un centre de pmi
effectivement généralement nous avons
des personnes en situation de
difficultés financières sociales
personnelles qui ont accès à ces 102 pmi
mais l'égal accès de tous à la pmi la
leçon d'universalité est un élément
moteur central des points
[Musique]
les centres de protection maternelle et
infantile et les centres de
planification et d'éducation familiale
propose des consultations gratuites et
sans rendez vous il offre des actions de
prévention dead à la maternité et sa
compagne dans la parentalité jusqu'à 6
ans les centres pmi sont composés d'un
personnel variés on peut y trouver des
sages-femmes des médecins des
puéricultrices des éducateurs des
auxiliaires des visites à domicile sont
également possibles
pour plus d'informations rendez vous sur
les sites du département au
www.defirh.fr 4 point fr lien social
accompagné les réunionnais pour la
mobilité rappelle victor natuelles je
viens de saint joseph de dunks arctic
survey bézaves j'ai 27 ans je suis
conducteur de travaux à aix en provence
alors conducteur de travaux c'est celui
qui organise les travaux avant et
pendant la pause dans le chantier alors
là on est sur la commune de peynier on a
une réfection totale de la venue du
cabaret une réfection totale des réseaux
dans le cadre de mon entreprise organisé
un pique nique créole pour associer à la
fois le côté créole et le côté
professionnel mon patron était très très
satisfait de la deûle à débarder fois
ici on me pose la question si je suis
pas ch'ti parce que j'ai un dax en mai
ils savent pas trop d'où ça vient c'est
sa civic ans un bouquet très heureux
hahaha
[Musique]
oh